okay this next interview with Lisa
Kudrow was recorded before we moved into
the Largo theatre which explains why
it's recorded in my backyard
my guest tonight of course an Emmy
award-winning actress who played Phoebe
on friends she also created and starred
in the critically acclaimed series the
comeback and web therapy and her new
series space force is streaming right
now on Netflix please welcome our trite
friend Lisa Kudrow Lisa how are you good
I like your background this is a picture
of my backyard well that's nice yeah cuz
otherwise let me show you what you'd be
dealing with okay let's see it I want to
and I dressed it this is what's that
it's a baby I'll put some flowers make
it pretty looks like you're visiting
your great-aunt that's what it looks
like come on is there plastic on the
furniture on the front so here's what
I've been thinking about preparing to
talk to you which is I've known you for
a long time and you are the person who I
would say has been preparing for this
pandemic since the day I met you you've
just you are someone who first of all
you studied biology at chemistry by
curiously you always used to be telling
me over the years a pandemic could be
coming and you like to hunker down now
it's happening are you adjusting
adjusting there was no adjusting it was
just there were days where I just never
even left my house or when this is the
question a lot of couples are up against
your significant other you and Michelle
yeah are you guys doing in this lockdown
are you getting honey what's really
working is he's mostly in and living in
another city right now so that's exactly
yeah where is Michelle he's in the
desert well he's here now but he spends
a lot of time in the desert spends a lot
of time in the desert he sounds like
roaming around no he sounds like Jesus
sounds like Moses just wandering around
is he come back spiritually enlightened
when he goes when he's wandering in the
desert for like 30 days he's 400 years
old are you good at this zoom thing I've
gotten a little bit better at it yeah I
think I got pretty good at it and then
pretty good at it and then I had a board
meeting for you know I'm at Vassar
you're on the board at Vassar College
your alma mater yes I knew that
and and by the way it was my very last
board meeting
oh why I could attend because I didn't
have to go there
but at the very last one and that's a
very big deal it's been 16 years you've
been on the board at Vassar College for
16 years
yes because I'm gonna have your last
meeting that's gotta be a little
emotional and it's on zoom' and it's on
zoom' but I think they said they were
gonna sort of carve out time because
usually at the when you're there there's
a dinner and you you know say goodbye
with meaningful speech something you
know so I was thinking about you know
what I was going to say and then out of
nowhere it felt it was okay so this is
Lisa's last meeting we know she's gotta
go so early so and I and I just went oh
no I don't have to go early mm-hmm and
nothing's happening the president of the
school has started to address me
president Bradley I'm like no I don't
have to go home I'm you okay no I don't
have to go she's still not doesn't seem
to hear man like but they can't hear you
because I didn't press it oh no I'm
trying to listen I missed everything she
said other than and I'm talking to her
and I said oh my god I'm talking to
Phoebe and I went really
that's how I came off like someone who
doesn't know what evolution is like and
then it just seemed like sit all right
well so you have a lot to do and we have
a lot to do of course they have a lot to
do in the middle of all this so thank
you Lisa and I just went okay well bye
and hung up
so someone there texted me and just
wrote boo let's talk about something
super happy which is this highly
anticipated friends reunion and then it
gets rushed because of this this crisis
we're all going through yeah so I know
that that must have felt a little bit
like oh we're gonna do this now but wait
no now we're not gonna do it for a while
do you know when you're doing it we have
something on on the books mm-hmm to do
it you know at some point in August and
we'll see I mean we're all still waiting
for guidelines for shooting things right
hopefully yeah that would be great you
know would really piss people off is you
if you guys did it but it was on Zoom so
the highly-anticipated all of you
getting together was zoom you're not in
the same room and you can't really hear
each other that well and then you say
well there it is
goodbye America come on there'd be a fun
prank that would be great that would be
so good and then freezing it's like I'll
never forget the time yeah yeah remember
remember Jennifer that time that you did
that thing we never forgave you for
which was and you all freeze and then
you come back and you're all laughing
that's fantastic I would love that just
do that please I'm good at thinking of
ideas that ruin things and that's what I
think would be would be a great prank
great prank wait can I ask you something
yeah so for um first spaceforce yes we
did this this game night thing mm-hmm
most of the cast for space force was
there and I was winning it was tied
between me and Steve Carell mm-hmm and
what we had to do was go into our house
and trying to some novelty mug and then
that would decide who won so he and
first thing I could think of Conan was
this
does this look familiar to you yes right
you remember that yes right and so I
don't even I was so happy and I just
said this this is from Conan's
first year on late-night and there
wasn't even it didn't even say Late
Night with Conan O'Brien and I have it
and this is it but is that right
yeah I think so I think we we did early
on they weren't sure I was gonna make it
so they didn't want to put my name on
any of the mugs they just wanted if
another host took over they wanted to
just peel to to use the same mugs so yes
you're right I think that's from the
first season when pre-cut Priya my name
on anything and so did you win because
of that yes because it was TV history
like they all viewed it as okay that is
TV history back yes monumental yes but I
woke up in the middle of the night and I
thought wait I wasn't on Conan's show
its first year but I think you got a mug
ha no I think we are friends and you you
visited and I think you took one I'd you
see right now remember when you used to
I don't know if you want this out or not
but used to steal things take things a
lot well number me rephrase that in the
90s
you stole things and thanks after the
first year my name story to go on stuff
I'm starting about a year ago they
started taking it off stuff again it
must be fun getting to work with me it's
a great cast space force and you're
working with my old writing partner Greg
Daniels
this must be yeah this is we used to all
hang out in the day back long time ago
yeah Greg Daniels is my writing partner
and this is back when I think you knew
me when Greg and I shared everything
everything we shared a car so if one of
us got a date we had to ask two but the
other one to borrow the car we shared an
apart
mint we had desks that faced each other
at work and I think after a year and a
half we wanted to kill each other we
absolutely wanted to kill each other
it was sort of preparation for right now
yes that was our preparation for this
time we're going through yeah
quarantined after college together I'm
really thrilled that you had the time to
speak with me all right you have plenty
of time usually I'm thanking you for
like oh you came all the way to Warner
Brothers to come do the show that's
really nice of you and now it's you know
but thank you I do
that's my curtain I dressed my beige
curtain for you you did
you stole plants from a Hallmark shop it
looks really nice I'm very excited about
space force and I want to make it the
plug out right now space force is
streaming now on netflix everybody check
it out Lisa I bow to you as I always do
[Music]
that wasn't about what you did you went
it looked like you were gonna throw up
when you bow well okay I took us down a
bad road what I bow to you
I bow to you I bow to you